we've got windy conditions across
southern nevada it's getting windier the
airport going to be a little bumpy of
people flying in or taking off today so
just hold on to those seats a little bit
tighter good air quality though because
these are north winds and north winds
always clean out the air for us so happy
about that but the winds have been up to
30 miles an hour in boulder city near 30
at mccarran already north las vegas 28
nellis air force base 25. now we don't
have wind advisories for the valley but
we do out at lake mead as well as along
the river and those will start in just a
little more than an hour this morning
and last all day until this evening i'll
tell you more in a minute a lot of 50s
out there but it's mainly because the
breezes are keeping the temperatures up
we've had clear skies overnight a few
clouds pass through but not enough to
keep temperatures above normal we should
really be in the 40s 35 at red rock 27
up there at kyle canyon not much wind in
the mountains this morning 43 in
mesquite 31 in caliani and look at those
teams up in ely again so a cold front
has been moving through the state and
you can really tell tone upon reno in
the 20s this morning indian springs not
much wind in the 30s some breezes in
trump at 45 more wind again expected
along the river today 61 there right now
so we've got some scattered snow showers
across the intermountain west the
northern plains denver a little bit of
snow albuquerque's had some snow
strong santa anas for southern
california today if you are traveling
there for the holiday weekend and it's
been pretty chilly across the midwest
but temperatures are actually rebounding
into the 40s in chicago where they had
teens and 20s earlier this week for
morning lows but look at those cool 30s
on the east coast take the nice warm
coat warm clothing you'll need it
through the holiday while showers are
moving off to the east i will have good
sunshine today but those wind advisories
for the lake and river start at 8 a.m
until 7 p.m and the first freeze warning
of the season actually
starts early tomorrow morning through
mid-morning tomorrow thanksgiving for
mohave county northwest arizona 62 so
we're back to where we really should be
with seasonal norms today and northwest
breezes that will stick around all right
bb we're looking at the channel 8 bus
it's the eight news now bus come on tom
turkey get on the bus it's going to be
beautiful tomorrow low 60s for highs
into the 50s through the dinner time
early evening hours but at least we've
got sunshine we're grateful for that
hanukkah begins at sundown sunday and
look at those 70s to finish november and
start december next week